at the October 13 1988 presidential
debate Michael Dukakis in George HW Bush
were asked who are the heroes who are
there in American life today who are the
ones that you would point out to young
Americans as figures who should inspire
this country I'm asked allanté via
darris those people that took us back
into space again
sports heroes Vice President Bush
eventually responded with I think a
doctor foul she probably never heard of
you did and heard of he's a very fine
research top doctor at National
Institute of Health working hard doing
something about research on this disease
of AIDS today dr. Anthony SOG is best
known because of his position in the
coronavirus task force and for his many
media appearances in the u.s. he's one
of the most recognizable faces in the
current crisis how did this doctor go
from his research lab in Bethesda
Maryland to becoming one of the most
visible medical experts on the pandemic
today thank you so much for taking the
time to watch you see a doctor Anthony
pouchy
the June 5th 1981 weekly report by the
Centers for Disease Control was a
notable one it recorded five unusual
cases of pneumonia these cases would
become known as some of the earliest
reports of AIDS the next year dr.
Anthony Fauci wrote in early paper about
the disease which had increased to 290
recognized cases and had become a public
health problem of essentially epidemic
proportions
now she worked at the National Institute
of Allergy and Infectious Diseases diet
heading up a lab that studied immune
system response
nayad conducts research on diseases to
help understand treat and prevent them
it falls under the National Institutes
of Health or NIH the medical research
agency part of the Department of Health
and Human Services in early 80s the NIH
had many Institute's with nayad and
National Cancer Institute leading
investigation of the new virus and
disease that would become known as
hiv/aids Pfau she made that
investigation the focus of his career
today we're going to be listening to dr.
Anthony Fauci he's going to be talking
about AIDS I'm working directly on on
AIDS both clinically and from a basic
science standpoint that really is one of
the few of more actually one of the only
subjects where you really have to change
your lecture every month though she was
named director of Nyad in 1984 and the
then director of Health and Human
Services highlighted vouches background
in immunology and infectious diseases as
a mean reason for his appointment AJ was
directed at determining if a variant of
this virus could actually cause
depletion of lymphocytes or acquired
immunodeficiency syndrome and as it
turned out a variant of that virus in
fact caused the center of velji's
leading early research helped define
Nyad as the central NIH Institute for
AIDS and he made it a point to be the
person communicating key findings to the
public and media the scientific data is
overwhelming
that in fact aids cannot be transmitted
by casual contact but it was a later
political test that shows how foul she
navigated the AIDS crisis and secured
his career in the summer of 1988
playwright Larry Kramer wrote an open
letter to Anthony fashi calling him an
incompetent idiot and a murderer his
opinion was broadly reflective of
activists most notably the organization
kramer inspired the AIDS coalition to
unleash power or act up in 1986 fowey
had reinforced his position as the
leading scientist for the federal-aid
Zephyr
he created a new division to focus on
the disease and earned other significant
NIH posts but progress was slow
especially for a disease as deadly as
AIDS where patients died on average 15
months after diagnosis pouchy and Nyad
were responsible for starting trials for
new drugs which the FDA required for
approval in June 1986 Nyad created a
network of clinical trial centers around
the country though they were criticized
as ineffective activists argued that the
NIH the FDA and leadership up to prison
Reagan had failed to take the crisis
seriously
this photo from an October 1988 protest
shows the key complaints at the time the
FTAs lengthy drug approvals required
strict scientific clinical trials it was
textbook science but the disease killed
at a faster pace than the FDA's process
if you entered a trial a certain
percentage of patients got the drug and
a certain percentage got a placebo
this helped test if the drugs were safe
and if they really worked that was
important because many AIDS drugs didn't
pan out but with aids getting a placebo
was a death sentence and that meant
fewer volunteers for clinical trials the
epidemic needed a radical approach but
experimental approaches like aerosolized
pentamidine weren't being approved the
drug helped treat one of the most common
infections caused by AIDS
yet trials had been delayed by nya which
she blamed on insufficient staff under
pressure he acknowledged the approval
problem in 1988 testifying in Congress
that he would go for what is available
on the street if he were a patient a
blunt rebuke to FDA policy keeping these
new approaches out of reach foul she
also went on to admit that it took them
a long time to start trials of dextran
sulfate a drug that had early enthusiasm
among AIDS patients for the few approved
options like the venn promising drug AZT
activists criticized the high prices
charged by maker Burroughs Wellcome all
these issues had spawned large networks
of buyers clubs AIDS patients who pooled
their resources to import non
fda-approved drugs in 1990 activists
staged another major protest this time
at the NIH in Bethesda Maryland where
foul she worked it was a turning point
in two key ways fashi incorporated these
sharp activists criticisms and ideas
into the government response in 1999
invited activist representatives into
the administrative committee's for every
AIDS clinical trial group this allowed
for the government response to include
on-the-ground knowledge starting in 1989
foul she had also voiced support for
new program called parallel track
forcing the FDA to consider it in it
patients who couldn't participate in
clinical trials could still get
unapproved drugs once they've been
tested for basic safety even if some
drugs didn't work at least they would be
available to try the de act up stormed
the NIH in May 1990 the Federal Register
published the FDA's plans to adopt a
parallel track plan
I'm dr. Anthony pouch nineteen years
before Brad Pitt played in Phaneuf ouchy
on Saturday Night Live SNL cast member
Chris Kattan played him in 2001 drive
during an anthrax scare two decades ago
pouchy was already the face of public
health response to unusual diseases that
included everything from anthrax and flu
updates to running the US government's
massive AIDS treatment program in Africa
under president george w bush all that's
helped his relationship with activists
bouchy called larry kramer a dear friend
who was a longtime nemesis I remember he
wanted to get my attention by writing an
open letter to that incompetent idiot
dr. Tony Fauci
he needed to stir the pot by staying in
the same role at Nyad since 1984 ouchy
became a fixture across five NIH
directors eight Centers for Disease
Control directors and eight surgeons
general they're appointed by the
President and foul he's been around for
six of them as the director of Nyad he's
insulated from that political element
the AIDS response in particular
illustrates how fat she manages
stakeholders from inside and outside the
government and from above in below his
position that in his scientific
expertise has made him a constant during
a new crisis to our recent advances of
being able to isolate identify and
characterize the agent together with the
advances in understanding the natural
history and pathophysiology of this
disease will allow us over the next year
to come back to you and tell you that we
now not only have hope and hypothesis
but that we have a real prevention and
indeed a real cure
[Music]
you
you